for all these years i thought godzilla
was my bro but then i watch this new
trailer
and he's smashing cities up they're
embarrassing me i told him we were
friends
okay so the new godzilla vs kong teaser
is completely breaking the internet
right now
and the titan level trailer has one big
question hanging over it
why is godzilla destroying the cities
and is he really the one doing it
well throughout this video we're going
to be breaking it all down and going
over our thoughts and theories on what's
really going on
there will be heavy spoilers here as
we'll be discussing some of the leaks
but nothing beyond what you could learn
from the trailer if you are looking
close enough
if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul the mega g when it
comes to breakdowns
now will the real godzilla please stand
up
okay so the premise of godzilla vs kong
makes it seem like the towering titan
has had enough of fish and ships
and he's decided to move his attention
to land monarch
are stumped fanboys are outraged and
absolutely
no one knows why the jolly green giant
has decided to turn on the people that
love and adore him
it's soul crushing and i don't mean that
he stepped on the capital of south korea
even though it looks like he may have
having that
now clearly something else is going on
and from the trailers
it looks like humanity has decided to
take kong in order to stand his chance
against the atomic breath breathing
behemoth
but what if it's all just one big
misunderstanding and the king of the
monsters is
actually being framed for what we see
him doing well if you go over the
trailer with a fine-tooth comb
you'll notice that there are two
distinct moments that confirm
mechagodzilla is indeed in the movie
after the initial attack that opens
things up
you can clearly see his classic metallic
shape moving over the citizens
that we see hurtling down the stairs
faster than i clicked the trailer video
when i got the notification from warner
brothers
i'm not ashamed to admit that now in
another part of the first look
we can see the character ren sarazawa
standing in front of a control panel
with a distinct metallic titan shape on
it that has writings saying
system reading at maximum charge ren is
actually the son of hiroshira played by
ken watanabe in the prior movies
and it's clear that he's inherited his
father's understanding of the titans
and has managed to craft his own the
place that we see him in
is clearly a mechagodzilla control room
and this signifies to me that he is
definitely being used by the humans
now if you've been keeping up to date
with the plots and oppositions that have
been released for the movie
you'll know recently there was one drop
that said the terrorist group apex were
looking to find a way to wipe out all
the titans in one fell swoop
apex themselves are rumored to have
built the beast through wren
who has used the brain of the severed
godora head from king of the monsters
and the gigantic titan skeleton from the
2014 godzilla film
though he appears in a very small way in
the trailer
he's clearly going to be laced
throughout the film and this is even
shown in the logos which have a distinct
blue electricity
flowing through them now because of his
dad it's difficult to tell whether ren
is going to be a good or bad guy
but if toby maguire has told me one
thing it's that people with this haircut
tend to be completely evil however i do
think that he may have been tricked by
apex
who would have been like look i know i
knew your dad
in a way after i tried to kill but we
we'd love to have you on board
now though we know little about apex
apparently they are trying to lure kong
and godzilla out into the open
so that they can have the pair fight
against one another and then when the
winner is weakened
they'll simply send mechagodzilla in to
finish them off
not finish them off like that you dirty
bad boy now this technique is something
that we saw expect to demonstrate with
the siamese fighting fishing from russia
with love
and it's commonly a tactic used in most
vs movies
where the two opposing sides then team
up to take out the greater evil
so it definitely is a possibility that
mechagodzilla could be the one carrying
out the attacks on the cities
in order to make the real one look bad
i've even saw theories on my trailer
breakdown that said mecca could be
wearing a gigantic kevlar suit
that just makes him look like godzilla
and it's like when you were a kid and
used to stand on your mates shoulders
and wear a trench coat to sneak into the
cinema
also i've been told because i didn't
have any friends however i'm going to
say
something controversial something that
you might want to sit down for
if you hashtag team godzilla okay you
sitting down
all right well i don't actually think
that mechagodzilla is the one who's
doing most of the city smashing
and i think it is indeed godzilla which
pains me to say
now in one scene in the trailer we can
see him blasting out his atomic breath
and this then sweeps across and causes
many casualties in the explosion
that arise from it now it may be a
kevlar suit yeah
but i think that the trailer in several
ways is hinting to us that both the
titans are
under some form of control or another
with kong we see a young girl who holds
up an idol that seems to calm down the
gigantic ape
and throughout the teaser there's lip
service paid to the fact that the pair
have a special bond
whether he recognizes similarities in
her to the people that he's eaten in the
past we don't know
but we very much have this idea that it
can be manipulated in some form or
another
even if it's willingly similar to this i
believe that kong will be under the
control of apex
who rather than playing their hand have
found a way to manipulate godzilla
into going wild in the middle of a city
king of the monsters clearly
demonstrated that the orca device was a
way to bring the titans under control
and i believe that this technology has
been perfected
and placed into mechagodzilla as a way
to have the metallic monster manipulate
godzilla into destroying the humans
now i am more than willing to accept
that it could be a possibility
that mechagodzilla is just dressed up as
the titan
but i feel like that cheapens the battle
in many ways if it turns out to be true
what we really want to see is both kong
and godzilla fight
and to have the reveal that it wasn't
him taking part in the action scenes
i think would make the movie just feel
very shallow
as much as i love godzilla i'd love it
if we had a moment like in batman v
superman
where kong says you were never a god
zilla
and just smacks him in the face well
that's probably just wishful thinking
now the reason that i think
mechagodzilla is able to manipulate the
other titans including the big dog
himself
is because in the trailer we see two
nuzuki titans that are attacking kong
according to the leaks these are natives
of skull island
however they also say that this place is
now more of a sanctuary to the titans
in which they've all fallen under the
rule of kong rather than constantly
being at war with one another
thus them attacking him does signify to
me that they may also have been sent
crazy by the twisted ways of apex
though this might not be the case it's
even possible that the explosion which
we see at the start of the trailer
is actually the energy override of
mechagodzilla which will draw the real
one to the area
and then have him go ape [ __ ] when the
orca is activated
yes pun intended i feel like these are
probably the most likely possibilities
and though it pains me to say i do think
that the godzilla we see in the trailer
is indeed the real one it just makes the
most sense to me that he's the one
causing all this death and destruction
and if the rumored monster verse is
going to spring from this film
i think the best place to start is with
the humans not really knowing whether
they can trust him or not
now if you agree with me or if you don't
i'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments section below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of january
in which we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theory
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full trailer
breakdown of the movie which will be
linked on screen right now
we go over all the easter eggs things
you missed and
give more of our in-depth theories so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time you take care of
yourself peace